well I think there are many people and I
hesitate to name some at the at the
exclusion of others but that would be
very good news that the president would
recognize that we need a chief
technology officer the many people who
could fill that bill first name i think
that would not offend anyone because
he's so great and everyone knows it
would be Sid drel who was the former
director of the linear accelerator at
Stanford and now his daughter is but he
is a respected person in the technology
field I'd be interested in he said
drought thought would be good but it
would be a giant step forward for our
country because the investments that we
must make in technology hold the answers
for our issues that relate to health
care innovation global warming
rebuilding infrastructure of America
everything depends on investments in
science and technology
you